area we should be i should notice you
should know macon
the city of naked here bibb county
actually just reported its early
absentee vote and joe biden got a big
batch from there so that did bring him
back
uh close a little bit closer but
obviously it
talking about fulton county let's give
you a sense here
230 000 votes are so estimated
you know left to be coming in here to
get you see the marching bands running
with the same day
between those two places
[Music]
is
understand what we're expecting in terms
of the time horizon for this election
we're not a million miles
for arizona minnesota
uh nevada iowa like it doesn't seem like
there's any reason to expect that
there's all these super long
but we are getting explicit not just
warnings but almost promises
that it's going to be multiple days
before we get results in
georgia michigan wisconsin and
pennsylvania
yeah i mean you just heard the report on
georgia so
you know there's also i would just say i
don't want to forget about this
north carolina remains uncalled the
margin is
mail right now 76.00 are postmarked they
will still be
counted we don't know how many there are
so that's another variable we're trying
to figure out how many more ballots are
going to come in
in north carolina could that still
plausibly affect the outcome in north
carolina had about 75
000 vote margin um in wisconsin
we do that we are hearing milwaukee i
think you were talking about this
earlier
you know core democratic area you see a
lot of
in the um elections
me
yes
is
separate places
you know in milwaukee milwaukee county
you've got a few waukesha
i think there's 38 there's 39 of these
these are municipalities generally
larger places
that do that sort of separate from the
county
and those can come in later in a lot of
cases and i think milwaukee is going to
be one of them
thank you very
quite confident much who has retained
the same
is
everybody chill put you know put away
the sharp instruments we're gonna be
fine
i i am a little i am more worried about
the senate although
interestingly in montana i just took a
look
and steve bullock is uh has
the same number of votes as as donald
trump and montana
with half the vote counted um you know
six thousand more votes than joe biden
now you say well six thousand that's not
that much but this is montana
uh six thousand is a lot so the fact
that he is running
ahead of joe biden by that much may
break
[Music]
um first of all i'm still recovering
from my glow against north carolina and
i and i know that
being the story of the night i love mark
but the fact is that the bible campaign
is in the exact
same sort of place and mood that they
were
in over the weekend where their number
one path to 270 is
to re or to resurrect the blue wall
of pennsylvania michigan and wisconsin
can you talk about
um
that would be all they need especially
if arizona continues to look the way it
looks
right now but can you can you just sort
of bring it back to the facts bring it
back to the map
well we were giddy because the map felt
like it was expanding
and i think we still have a polling
problem in this country you know we
thought that they had
made adjustments and napoleon was now
absolutely correct
based on polling it looked like there
were all kinds of different paths we
could get there
as it turned out the one true path is
the path
that they were most focused on give this
campaign credit
um you know joe biden did joe biden
didn't go to texas
everyone was screaming go to texas
um they knew they had to keep their eye
on the prize which was
which were those three states and those
three states
i believe will deliver the presidency
just as
campaign
but it does look like a state that's
very promising um you know look very
promising also for
mark kevin um in the end i'm getting
some
sort of trump world people who are
texting that they already feel like
you know donald trump is
you know in the end if it plays out that
way
uh joe biden that extra that extra state
that he needs
it could be uh and you know obviously
all this campaign
and he needs just a few others and the
ones that he's got left are easier
than arizona yeah i need to jump in here
for a second nbc
users are going to change slightly the
characterization
of the race in one state uh it relates
to the state of
minnesota now it has been too early to
call there it remains
too early to call in the state of
minnesota but nbc is now adding the
characterization
that joe biden leads
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
i mean like she could recite to you
every library address
in every county of every state this is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
and clearly there have been some
disappointments in the senate race
so the mental health around that is
probably going to be as difficult
as making it more difficult than
the reality that everybody has to be
patient
uh
and ultimately the people who voted in
those states
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
to uh
[Music]
mccurry overcome carry edward's campaign
and i
we were the black channel and we sort of
created a dynamic where we talked to
both our candidates and no one said
anything
um
[Music]
is
uh
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
huh
please welcome vice president
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
good evening your patience is
commendable
we knew this was gonna go wrong but who
knew we're gonna go
into maybe tomorrow morning maybe even
longer
but look we feel good about where we are
we really do
i'm here to tell you tonight we believe
we're on track to win this election
[Applause]
we knew because of the unprecedented
early vote in the mail-in vote
that's going to take a while we're going
to have to be patient
until we uh the hard work of tallying
the votes is finished
and it ain't over until every vote is
counted every ballot is counted
but we're feeling good we're feeling
good about where we are
we believe one of the nets has suggested
we've already won
arizona but we're confident about
arizona that's a turnaround
we also just called it from minnesota
and we're still in the game in georgia
although
that's not what we expected
we're feeling real good about wisconsin
and michigan
and by the way it's going to take time
to count the votes we're going to win
pennsylvania
we're talking to folks in philly
allegheny county scranton
and they're really encouraged by the
turnout and what they see
look you know we could know the results
as early as tomorrow morning but it may
take a little longer as i've
said all along it's not my place or
donald trump's place to declare
who's won this election that's the
decision of the american people
but i'm optimistic about this outcome
i want to thank every one of you who
came out and voted in this election and
by the way chris coons and the democrats
congratulations here in delaware
hey john give the gov yeah like the
whole
team man you've done a great job i'm
grateful
to the poll workers to our volunteers
our canvassers
everyone who participated in this
democratic process
and i'm grateful to all my supporters
here in delaware and all across the
nation
thank you thank you thank you and folks
you heard me say it before every time i
walk out of my grandpa's house up in
scranton he yelled joey
keep the faith and my grand mom and
she's live you'll know joey spread it
keep the faith guys we're going to win
this thank you thank you thank you
your patience is great let's walk over
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
keep it up
[Music]
[Music]
hi
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
i can stand up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
you